have you nailed like his sexy French
accent what I'm saying
hmm let's go really well I'm young
welcome back to grammar with me joshing
some host and today backstage L'Oreal
Paris Fashion Week Church about Eva
Longoria now what we're gonna do so is
gonna play a game called be more Ava
okay so I want you to teach me how to be
totally worth it in my everyday life
okay
and also if I was gonna hit that runway
today how would I do it like you okay so
now I number one how can I be worth it
what is your go-to p.m. a mantra would
you say positive mental attitude
I actually live by a Maya Angelou quote
which is people won't forget what you
said and don't forget what you did but
they'll never forget how you made them
feel
and so trying every day they have
authentic conversations with people
whether it's about the weather or
whether it's about fashion or just being
kind and giving everybody an experience
with you that the only yeah go to show
so I would have been Natasha poly yeah
living weight cuz she is like giraffe
leg and then she doesn't a crossover
thing I don't I'm scared of all of it
now what is your best half licking worth
it move but yeah I'm always enormous but
there were nearly no commercials because
you all come like the queen of sassy on
the hip that girl in the hair for it
I was it no hips being the hip state lie
which is a cue and you're also supreme
girl bass uh-huh you are major what are
your top tips of bossing everyday life
apologize warrant I think women who tend
to go oh could you get my bones so sorry
I really need it now it's like don't you
let it now from your village oh so I
think really really moving into to the
delegation and the leadership of it
and if I'm just like goodness dropping
down that runway and I spot cute boy in
the crowd what's my kind of life and
then more mysterious also yeah I like
that so when it comes to working your
everyday beauty routine or what gives
you the most confidence to say what
beauty product is the most common yeah
cuz I think it I get some spots really
easily when I'm in the Sun and I'm
always uncomfortable I'm like I'm in my
car or I'm sitting talking somebody at a
cafe I'm just so sick hear about it and
so if I have some buckle and it gives me
all the companies in the world but I'm
like I'm fine I'm fine
got my SPF and that's how you can be
worth it
[Music]